this episode is brought to you by nebula
the streaming platform built by and for
youtubers like me
i've also got some new merch for sale
help support my channel and get a free
month of nebula with every purchase by
following the link below
the cia from the very beginning at least
as early as 1951
has used the information that it is
collected and it has used the
information
in order to penetrate and to manipulate
the institutions of power
in whatever country it is operating in
order to influence the course of events
in those countries
and essentially this uh boils down to
propping up those forces which are
considered to be the friendly forces
and in penetrating dividing weakening
and ultimately
destroying those forces which are
considered to be the enemy forces
[Music]
since its very inception as the office
of strategic services
the clandestine operations group known
today as the central intelligence agency
has engaged in some of the worst
atrocities in modern history
in this episode we're going to take a
brief look at some of the crimes of the
cia
and consider the possibility that maybe
the good guys aren't so good after all
the men and women of the central
intelligence agency
without you our nation's safety
would be more vulnerable in our security
fraudulent and endangered
the work you do each day is essential to
the
survival into the spread of human
freedom
you remain the eyes and ears of the free
world
you are the tripwire over which the
totalitarian rule must stumble in their
quest for global domination
as with every aspect of american life
the functions of the cia are hailed as a
way to protect freedom and democracy
its agents are applauded as heroes on
the surface the notion of gathering
information to better understand the
capabilities of other nations seems
harmless enough
but as you probably already know the cia
is not simply the ears of the nation
they're also instigators propagandists
spies saboteurs
torturers and all too often murderers
this is a huge topic and one that i
can't possibly fit into a short video
so i'll leave a bunch of links to other
resources in the description we're going
to focus on some of the big picture
stuff
let's start with election meddling
according to u.s politicians there's
nothing more sacred than free and fair
elections
we accuse other nations of meddling all
the time recently it's been russia iran
and china getting the accusatory finger
pointed at them
but as much as we want to project an
image of our nation as a shining beacon
of truth and freedom
we are the worst offender when it comes
to meddling in foreign affairs
and it's not even close the cia isn't a
fan of subtle manipulation
the intelligence agency wants the world
to see the results of whatever election
or administration they're disrupting
what they don't want is for people to
know they're the ones pulling the
strings according to one study
the cia had engaged in 81 overt or
covert interventions in foreign affairs
between 1945 and 2000
and that's just the ones we know about
and not even counting the constant
meddling and destabilization of the last
20 years
the cia's weapon of choice for foreign
meddling is the military coup
one of the earlier examples is the
overthrow of the democratically elected
prime minister of iran
based on what you know about u.s
priorities and the resources of the
middle east
what do you think was the catalyst for
this coup if you said oil
congratulations you're right the u.s
beating up other countries for their oil
isn't just a meme
masada had nationalized the iranian oil
company which negatively affected u.s
and british economic interests
to make matters worse from a u.s
perspective masada
while not a communist himself had earned
the support of the iranian communist
party
as you'll come to see one whiff of
successful non-capitalist economics and
the cia is called in to destroy
everything
in this particular instance winston
churchill and president eisenhower
decided to overthrow the government of
iran
the cia paid some of tehran's most
violent mobsters to stage protests
across the city
and orchestrated trucks and buses full
of people to come in and seize the area
between two and 300 people were killed
in the conflict
which of course the cia expected would
happen the intelligence agency then
propped up a government under the rule
of the shah
who reigned as a monarch heavily
dependent on u.s support to maintain
power
masada was arrested convicted of treason
by the new u.s friendly government
served three years in prison and spent
the remainder of his life under house
arrest
all for the crime of trying to lead his
country out from under the boot of
western imperialism
the truth about this coup wouldn't come
to light until 60 years later
in 2013 when cia documents on the
subject were declassified
these documents prove the cia's planning
and execution of the coup
their use of propaganda bribery of
politicians security and military
officials
and their approval at the highest levels
of government you may be thinking
okay if they declassified this
information that means they don't do
that kind of thing anymore right
well no have we ever tried to meddle in
other countries elections
oh probably but uh it was for the good
of the system in order to avoid the
communists from taking over for example
in europe
uh in 47 48 49 the greeks and the
italians we don't do that now though we
don't mess around in other people's
elections
only for a very good cause do that do a
vine video on those former ciao
only for a very good cause of the
interest of democracy
laura ingram clearly gave this guy the
chance to lie and say that we don't
meddle anymore but he didn't take it
the cia director openly bragged about
meddling in foreign affairs for quote
very good reasons call me idealistic but
i don't think there's any reason for a
country to disrupt the election process
of other nations
but here we are it's out in the open
that we do it to this day
here's another example of a cia
operative bragging about the types of
crimes the agency commits
we need to make the iranians pay a price
in syria we need to make the russians
pay a price
the other thing make them pay the price
by killing killing russians
yes and killing iranians yes covertly
so you don't tell the world about it
right you don't stand up at the pentagon
and say we did this
right but you make sure they know it in
moscow until here's the other thing i
want to do
here's the other thing i'm going to do i
want to go after i want to go after
those things that assad sees
as his personal power base
right i want to scare assad so i want to
i want to go after his presidential
guard
i want to bomb his offices in the middle
of the night well that happened about
two years ago as you remember when his
brother-in-law was i want to
destroy his presidential aircraft on the
ground i want to destroy his
presidential helicopters
i want to make him think we're coming
after him right
these people aren't exactly subtle about
the sabotage and violence committed by
their organization
but let's return to the past for a
minute there are plenty more coups to
discuss
another study found that the us was
responsible for no fewer than 61
attempts at regime change during the
cold war alone
all spearheaded by the cia just one year
after the overthrow of masada
the cia launched another coup to oust
jacobo arbenz the democratically elected
president of guatemala
this is the moment the cia established
itself as a weapon to be wielded by
western capital
the agency was approached by the united
fruit company a us-based corporation
because they were afraid new
anti-exploitation laws in guatemala
would negatively affect their profits
the cia also suspected guatemala had
ties to the ussr
and these two reasons were sufficient
for them to launch a coup oust the
guatemalan president
and install the first in a long line of
right-wing dictators friendly to
the u.s this coup also set the precedent
of the cia lying to the president
regarding casualties
so by 1954 we had a largely
unaccountable secret agency undermining
democracy and national sovereignty
around the world
this trend would continue throughout the
decades in 1963
the cia planned a coup that culminated
in the assassination of the president of
south vietnam
once again in the name of fighting
communism this particular coup
resulted in u.s involvement in a foolish
10-year war which cost the lives of 58
000 american soldiers and almost a
million vietnamese
many of whom were civilians the cia
would go on to launch coups in iraq
cuba the republic of congo laos the
dominican republic
brazil chile and countless other
countries each time
with little reasoning besides what
you're doing isn't ideal for the us
these coups often led to horrible
destabilization including civil war
economic depressions and hundreds of
thousands of deaths
over the course of their reign of terror
the cia would develop techniques to aid
them in the destruction of foreign
nations
one such batch of techniques was
compiled in a 90-page handbook titled
psychological operations in guerilla
warfare which was distributed to the u.s
backed nicaraguan contras
and detailed how armed propaganda teams
could build political support in
nicaragua for the contra cause through
deceit
intimidation violence and assassination
this was a trend that would prove very
useful to the u.s
by outsourcing their more heinous crimes
including over 50 assassination attempts
on world leaders
to local u.s friendly groups the cia
could maintain a level of plausible
deniability
here's former cia officer john stockwell
discussing his time in the agency and
what their goals were
they undertake to run operations in
every corner of the globe
they also undertook the license of
operating
just totally above and beyond u.s laws
they had a license if you will to kill
but also they
they took that to a license to smuggle
drugs
a license to do all kinds of things to
other people
in other societies and violation of
international
our law and every principle of nations
working together for a healthier and
more peaceful
world we manipulated and organized the
overthrow of functioning constitutional
democracies in other countries
we organized secret armies and directed
them to fight
in just about every continent in the
world we encouraged ethnic minorities
to rise up and fight people like the
mosquito indians in nicaragua
the kurds in the middle east amongst in
in southeast asia we have organized and
we still do and fund death squads in
countries around the world like the
treasury police in el salvador
which are responsible for most of the
killing of the 50 000 people
just in the 80s and there were 70 000
before that
an orchestration ci secret teams and
propaganda
led us directly into the korean war we
were attacking china from the islands
kemoi matsu thailand tibet
a lot of drug trafficking involved in
this by the way
until eventually we convinced ourselves
to fight the chinese in korean we had
the korean war and a million
people were killed same thing for the
vietnam war and we have extensive
documentation of how the cia was
involved
at every level or the national security
complex because it's a very cooperative
thing
into manipulating the nation into the
vietnam war
let me just put it this way the best
heads that i coordinate with studying
this thing we count at least minimum
figure six million people who've been
killed
in this long 40-year war that we've
waged against the people of the third
world
but funding coups and destabilizing
entire regions takes a lot of money
luckily for the cia their scope of work
was broad enough to include a
particularly lucrative industry
drug smuggling at least as far back as
the vietnam war
cia operatives were heavily involved in
trafficking drugs into the united states
cia planes would make routine trips to
and from places like costa rica and
honduras
working with cartels to secure massive
amounts of heroin and cocaine
which they would then shuttle back to
the u.s and sell for a healthy profit
because of their secretive line of work
these planes could land in places where
normal customs regulations don't apply
it's a dream scenario for drug smuggling
the piles of money the cia makes from
this practice have directly funded the
undermining of democracy throughout the
world
with the added effect of introducing
harmful drugs to the american population
drug running and coups are bad enough
but what really makes the cia a
terrorist organization is their fondness
for bizarre
questionable and sometimes downright
evil experiments
since the end of world war ii the
intelligence agency has experimented
with everything from chemical weapons to
biological weapons to mind control and
death rays
the cia is on a never-ending quest to
find new ways to secretly kill or
otherwise control their targets
you may have seen the movie the
manchurian candidate the film was based
on the cia's experimental mind control
program
where a subject would be hypnotized and
programmed with an activation word or
phrase
something that when heard would trigger
their cia training and turn them into a
sort of deadly automaton
the cia wanted to create these sleeper
agents and plant them in target
countries around the world
it sounds absurd but the cold war was a
scary time and the cia was a scary place
the secretive agency may have left the
notion of mind control behind
but what they haven't given up is
torture torture is something that no
human being should be capable of doing
to another
but it's part of the standard cia
toolkit and it has been for years
this really only came to the attention
of the american people during the iraq
war
when the horrific images from secret
prisons and black sites like abu ghraib
found their way onto u.s television
screens
waterboarding sensory and sleep
deprivation dogs
insects electrical shock all of these
and even more twisted techniques were
used to get supposed criminals to
confess
or get war prisoners to give up valuable
information for years the gruesome
details of america's so-called enhanced
interrogation program were hidden from
the public
bits of information trickled out slowly
over the course of the iraq war and the
years following
now nearly two decades after the cia
fabricated the intelligence that led us
into war with iraq
a fuller picture of the horrors of cia
black sites has been assembled
one prisoner 49 year old abu zubaida the
first person to be subjected to the
torture program approved by president
george w
bush has provided drawings of what he
experienced at a cia black site in
thailand
zubaida who was captured because the cia
mistakenly thought he was a top al-qaeda
lieutenant
describes waterboarding which he endured
83 times
being crammed into a tiny confinement
box meant to break his resolve
chained in so-called stress positions
for hours for example his wrist being
chained so high that he had to stand on
tiptoes he also depicts being hooded
chained in the fetal position and
tethered to a cell bar to prevent
movement
he describes a process known as walling
in which the prisoner has his head
banged into a wall
and when he falls down he's dragged back
up to his feet by a plastic wrapped
towel around his neck
another drawing shows a larger
confinement box pitch black with the
prisoner chained in a seated position
over a bucket which was meant to serve
as a toilet
zubaida also describes being deprived of
sleep for two to three weeks at a time
kept awake by having water thrown on him
and being chained in painful positions
this is the legacy of the cia during the
iraq war and for years after
cruel inhumane torture approved by the
very highest authority in the country
after the cia fabricated the reasons for
invading iraq in the first place
today the cia claims they no longer
torture human beings
instead they're known to train
non-americans to do it for them
to maintain their plausible deniability
the cia trains
observes and provides equipment to
foreign agents who are less constrained
by public outcry
the torture continues but now the cia
can claim that they're not the ones
doing it
the question you're probably thinking is
why why would our country allow this
organization to exist
it clearly doesn't protect freedom and
democracy like reagan claimed
the answer is simple the u.s wants to
maintain its number one spot
we're currently the sole world
superpower and in order to maintain that
position of power the country needs to
make sure that the rest of the world
depends on us
and it needs to make an example of
alternative economic structures that
would undermine the notion of american
capitalist supremacy
but don't just take it from me here's
former cia operative and whistleblower
philip agee talking about the u.s
relationship with cuba and why we were
so adamant in destroying them
so it's not hopeless but you see how the
united states is going around
in these areas of economics and of trade
and of commerce
and finance to try to
make the cuban people suffer as much as
they can
and this is affecting in a drastic way
very young children and infants and also
the older
in other words the most vulnerable and
it is a it is an
eternal shame on the united states in my
opinion that we would do such a thing to
an entire country
just because we don't like the system
just because they won't come under our
protection basically it's a kind of a
mafia
attitude and it has been that way since
eisenhower
well that's capitalism well it's also
the united states and uh
our tradition of being very nervous
when we don't control something and when
a country like cuba
slips out from under our control after
we had
ruled it practically as a neo-colony or
a protectorate
for 59 years or so
then it makes people nervous because
they know that
if the cubans are successful in their
example
of being able to provide as a poor
country
the best medical care in the third world
to the whole population
because it's an inclusion inclusionary
system it's not like we have here
where you have this huge bulk of the
population you know marginalized but
there
if everybody can have adequate medical
care
if the schooling is adequate for all and
remember cuba has
more doctors and more teachers per
capita than any country in the world
and they have succeeded in these areas
and it's all state
um supported which means people don't
have to put money out for
for the medical care or for um it's in
they of course pay the cost indirectly
as a whole society but they don't have
to pay the bill
in the hospital and so forth and so that
cannot be allowed to stand it's a very
bad example
for the united states so there's a very
large mass of people out there who can
look at cuba and say
well if they can do it and on a
per capita income of two thousand two
thousand five hundred dollars a year
where ours is twenty two thousand five
hundred dollars a year
what's wrong with what's wrong with our
system i mean maybe we
ought to consider an alternative
that's why nicaragua sounded eastern
nicaragua had to be destroyed
exactly they were a bad example and
that's why grenada had to be destroyed
because
any movement that comes to power
with the idea of providing for all the
people and
of escaping the control of the united
states
and its economy let's say the
corporations and so forth
then that is bad news here in the united
states in the upper uh
circles of power so there you go
it really is that simple the u.s wants
to maintain its global supremacy
and that requires destroying any
competing economic system to prevent
people from questioning capitalism and
it requires keeping the rest of the
world under the boot of the united
states
it's criminal and morally reprehensible
but who's going to stand up to the most
powerful bully in the world
for those of you thinking that this
doesn't matter because you live in the
u.s
i've got bad news for you in 1975 a u.s
intelligence committee found that the
cia owned more than 200 wire services
newspapers magazines and book publishers
and subsidized many more
a separate new york times investigation
revealed an additional 50 media
operations run by the cia
both within the u.s and abroad and
another 12 publishing houses which had
produced over 1200 books secretly
commissioned by the cia
ok what does this mean it means that the
cia has been running a secret propaganda
campaign on american citizens for almost
half a century
more recently the agency has awarded
contracts worth billions of dollars to
microsoft
ibm oracle amazon and google to complete
assignments issued by the cia
the central intelligence agency has its
tendrils in every single aspect of
modern life
books magazines movies television social
media and big tech
just as the cia works hard to undermine
freedom and democracy around the world
it also works hard to keep americans
convinced that they live in the greatest
country on earth
and that there is no alternative to
american supremacy
the cia is a terrorist organization the
biggest one in the world
and it needs to be abolished and its
records made public the united states
has no right to impose its will on the
rest of the world
and it certainly has no right to do it
in secret
this episode was sponsored by well me
actually and my streaming service nebula
you might know by now that nebula is a
streaming service created by creators
like me
where we get to experiment with the
kinds of content that tends to get
demonetized or removed by the algorithm
on nebula there are no sponsor messages
no censorship
and you'll get to see all my normal
content before it goes live on youtube
plus my fellow creators and i have
exclusive original content that you
won't be able to see anywhere else
for fans of second thought if you
purchase any of my merchandise you'll
get 30 days of nebula completely free
automatically so you'll get to support
me and new amazing educational content
plus get access to tons of shows from
your favorite creators ad free
we can't do this without your support so
head to standard tv
second thought check out my stickers
posters and t-shirts and get some great
nebula content on me
if you enjoyed this video consider
dropping a like if you hated it a thumbs
down
subscribe and click the bell to be
notified of every new episode you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
[Music]
you